la folie du patin à roulettes qui gagne
aujourd'hui le centre de new york
avec au coeur de central park une piste
d'entraînement réservée aux patineurs
sur fond de musique disco bien
évidemment
m
il y aurait aujourd'hui 28 millions
d'américains qui seraient devenus des
adeptes inconditionnels de ce nouveau
sport
juppé
tu es
officiellement on appelle ça le roller
skate mais on dit généralement le rôle
ère où le skate
alors restons français et parlons
simplement du patin à roulettes
il revient à la mode il revient en force
pendant la période de noël
il s'en est vendu comme des petits pains
on a retrouvé une paire de patins datant
de 1860
il ne s'agit donc pas d'une nouveauté
pour les enfants cela leur permet de
renouveler leur jeu de se dépenser
physiquement d'être en plein air un
bilan donc positif
des commerçants avisés ont ainsi vu
s'ouvrir des perspectives rentable
exemple ce dancing à la porte de paris
c'est le seul établissement de ce genre
existantes actuellement en france
et ça marche ou plutôt ça roule alors
une mode
parions plutôt pour une nouvelle
activité de loisir une des rares notons
le au passage à ne pas consommer de
pétrole
qui pourrait croire que ce touriste
débonnaire et modeste est l'inventeur
envier richissime de la trouvaille
géniale qu'est le rubik's cube
et pourtant voilà bien erno rubik
l'auteur de cette diableries qui calme
ou qui agace comme vous voudrez des
dizaines de millions de mains dans le
monde
en visite à paris pour le premier
championnat français du rubik's cube ce
hongrois tranquille architecte de
formation et professeur aux arts
décoratifs de budapest est aller en
pèlerinage au palais de la découverte
salle mathématiques géométriques
car le rubik's cube en descendent
directement 43 milliards de combinaisons
une seule solution c'est pour faire
comprendre à mes étudiants la
visualisation de l'espace que j'ai
construit mon rubicube car le cube en
général et parmi les corps géométriques
régulier la forme idéale dans la
multiplication permet de remplir
l'espace d'une façon continue ou le
contraire
la division par la démultiplication
d'où les six côtés à 9 face est soit 54
face être au total j'ai apporté une
certaine joie et je compte bien
continuer bientôt le public français
connaîtra mes autres inventions
je me fais plaisir à chercher à
réfléchir et j'ai envie de continuer
elle bat charleroi
côté droit d'auteur on parle de
plusieurs milliards de centimes rubik
reste discret et répond avec malice
l'argent existe il est en sécurité quant
au succès mondial
il est colossal 25 millions de rubik's
cube vendu au début j'ai laissé tomber
au bout d'un moment parce que j'arrivais
pas qu'après j'ai repris je sais pour
une méthode et à partir de la capf ont
dû aller au bout d'un an
est ce que tu es toujours de recherche
mance l'aspect recherche dans l'est ont
été pris pour aller plus vite sur une
quelque chose qu'on voit si souvent une
position contre souvent qu'après ça les
publics
google lequel est possible y en a
combien maintenant qu'un broker reste
l'avenir du rubik's cube en at il
seulement 1
pour certains ce n'est qu'un casse tête
dicté par la mode pour tous les autres à
commencer par les chercheurs
c'est un jeu déjà classique bref la ruby
comme annie pourrait bien se transformer
en rubik's au filet
et maintenant regarde
et regardez bien ce disque se disent que
c'est en principe le disque de l'avenir
l'adisq numérique
inusable ou presque hinault rentrer en
contact avec aucun objet puisque c'est
un rayon laser qui le sillonnent il faut
pour cela un appareil adéquate en vente
depuis hier dans les magasins de ici
alors patrick estève vous dit tout sur
le disque numérique
cette fois pour entrer dans notre cadre
de vie familiale le microprocesseur
cette puce savante inventé par
l'électronique du 20e siècle a choisi
une voie originale la musique
cet appareil est l'un des tout premier
lecteur laser de disques numériques
l'apparition de ce matériel représente
un bouleversement profond dans le monde
de la musique et de la haute fidélité
plus que cela encore c'est le symbole
d'une nouvelle forme d'industrie celle
des technologies de pointes appliqués
aux loisirs
ce petit disque de 12 cm de diamètre
seulement permet l'enregistrement d'une
heure de musique d'où son nom de
compacts disques à côté de lui
le traditionnel 33 tours fait déjà
figure d'ancêtre avec un tourne disque
classique une pointe frotte dans le
sillon du disque et se met à vibrer en
montant et en descendant le long des
boss du sillon avec le compact disc le
sillon disparaît remplacé par des
milliards de minuscules trous percés
suivant un code numérique que seul
l'ordinateur peut analyser
bien sûr ces trous sont si petits qu'une
aiguille ne peut plus les lire n'utilise
le faisceau de lumière d'un laser
cette combinaison ordinateur laser
permet toutes sortes d'amélioration il
est par exemple possible de programmer
l'ordre dans lequel on désire écouter
les différentes chansons d'un disque
mais surtout cette combinaison lazer
ordinateur permet d'obtenir un relief
sonore digne des meilleures
installations professionnelles sans
aucun souffle et sans bruit de fond si
vous décidez de vous équiper
pas besoin de tout changer ses lecteurs
se branchent sur n'importe quelle chaîne
hi fi
une seule ombre au tableau le prix des
appareils de 6000 à 8000 francs un prix
très élevé qui semble-t-il ne devrait
pourtant pas empêcher l'explosion du
marché de ce nouveau système
nous pensons que le 33 tours
traditionnel disparaîtra dans une
dizaine d'années
c'est donc une révolution relativement
rapide quant aux prix actuels
bien entendu c'est un prix élevé mais ce
prix élevé nous avait enclin à une
certaine prudence
or l'exemple du japon montre que ce prix
élevé est tout à fait accepté par le
public l'avantagent produits étant
tellement décisif que le public estime
que le rapport qualité prix est quand
même très très favorable et le japon
vingt mille machines mis sur le marché
au mois d'octobre
toutes ces machines ont disparu en
quelques jours c'est vous dire si
l'accueil du public a été très favorable
par comment ça se passe et pour les gens
qui veulent une grosse discothèque de 33
tours
les éditeurs transféreront sur le
compact disc les anciens documents
sonores dont ils peuvent disposer par
conséquent on peut penser que la plupart
des mélomanes remplaceront
progressivement dans les années qui
viennent leur ancienne discothèque qui
était sous forme de micro sim
traditionnelle par du compact disc au
rythme de l'usure de leurs micro sillon
on fabrique ce disque exactement comme
de satellites ou des microprocesseurs
dans de vastes usines entièrement
blanche
habillés de combinaisons de vinyle
l'ennemi numéro un
la poussière ici on travaille au micron
près une seule poussière sur le moule et
ce sont des centaines de disques perdu
30% de ceux qui sortent de cette presse
partent pour la poubelle
et lorsque cette usine a démarré la
chaîne il y a quelques mois plus de la
moitié étaient inutilisables
c'est dire à quel point la production de
ces disques est une affaire délicate
paradoxe du progrès technique
l'objet a fabriqué est petit plus il
faut une usine complexe est gigantesque
à ce jour trois usines seulement au
monde sont capables de produire ses
compacts disques la première en
allemagne à hanovre sur ces images
la seconde au japon la troisième aux
etats-unis est en cours d'implantation
al'inverse du magnétoscope le standard
du compact disc est international
standard unique qui amène aujourd'hui un
redéploiement mondial de l'industrie du
disque
cette usine des compacts disques a coûté
environ 90 millions de francs
naturellement c'est une somme que les
petites compagnies de disques ne peuvent
plus investir
seules les grosses compagnies peuvent se
le permettre et nous déjà nous sommes
prêts à nous à grandir et à passer à la
phase 2 c'est à dire investir encore 45
millions
cette nouvelle technologie risque donc à
terme de faire disparaître les petites
sociétés au profit de groupes très
puissants
la révolution technique du compact disc
n'est pas sans effet sur le plan social
et machine coûte tellement cher que pour
les amortir même cette usine qui ne
travaillait jusqu'ici avec deux équipes
vient d'instaurer les trois huit
une fois finie ce disque si délicat à
réaliser devient inusable inrayable la
musique qu'au départ l'ordinateur défie
le temps de nombreux chefs d'orchestre
contemporains ont compris la chance que
représente pour eux cette technique
herbert von karajan enregistre déjà
depuis plusieurs années en numérique
ainsi l'ordinateur permet aux
interprètes de devenir les égaux des
sculpteurs ou des peintres leurs oeuvres
pouvant enfin survivre à la mort et
c'est peut-être la plus belle
contribution du compact disc
sans transition nous allons parler d'eux
sujet qui vous concernent ou en tout cas
qui va vous concerne et très bientôt
dans votre vie quotidienne
je veux parler de l'informatique
l'informatique au quotidien pour le
moment on en est qu'à des expériences
car c'est une période de mutation mais
très bientôt ça deviendra une banalité
pour nos enfants pour ceux qui sont
là-bas derrière moi qui joue en ce
moment 1 avec des jeux d'éveil où ce
sera ça sera qu'une banalité
l'opération a été lancée hier par le
ministère des télécommunications
ça se passait georges leclercq en
picardie et en ile de france c'était
l'annuaire électronique
c'est cela que ce sera alors l'annuaire
électronique a déjà une histoire c'est
plus une expérience c'est déjà quelque
chose qui existe depuis longtemps
quand vous voulez téléphoner vous prenez
un butin si vous ne connaissez pas le
numéro de votre correspondant vous
cherchez dans le bottin est bien en ille
et vilaine depuis le début de l'année au
lieu de rechercher dans un bottin qu'on
n'a pas toujours voyez tous les bottins
qu'il faut on peut rechercher d'une
façon différente avec ce que vous avez
appelé noël l'informatique au quotidien
voilà la forme de cette informatique
c'est un minitel qui vous permet de
trouver des numéros de téléphone des
réclames les fameuses pages jaunes du
bottin est de retrouver un certain
nombre d'indications à partir soit du
nom soit de la localité et du nom soit
du prennent enfin avec des
renseignements incomplets
vous vous brancher sur un ordinateur fut
à vous donner des renseignements
complets c'est aujourd'hui installé en
ille-et-vilaine je crois qu'il ya
quarante mille abonnés et ça s'installe
maintenant quoi chez absolument
nécessaire
c'est plutôt un gadget
comment je trouve plus facile de prendre
la nuit à paris et deux au québec
ce qu'il ya c'est un facial parce que
c'est la mise à jour et rapid génial
mais autrement
et puis vous êtes peut-être votre
internationale voilà et numéro courant
j'ai pas besoin de l est recherché comme
ça spécial oui je travaille dans la
micro informatique et pour moi c'est
intéressant tant que commerçante d'avoir
accès à des listes l'adresse par
profession par exemple et pour cela
explique que m'intéressait beaucoup
alors vous voyez deux réactions les uns
ont bien compris les autres ne
l'utilisent pas finalement
mais on ne jettera pas les bottins la
poubelle comme vous le voyez sur cette
image on va continuer à utiliser le
papier et l'ordinateur alors
l'ordinateur vous voulez une petite
démonstration h et j'adore vos gadgets
et que je devrais démonstration j'ai une
idée qui est de rechercher un monsieur
qui s'appelle joyeux dans j'ignore
l'orthographe exacte et je vais regarder
vous le voyez ici
si monsieur joyeux que je connais qui
habite bien à paris peut se retrouver
dans cet annuaire électronique qui n'est
qu'un ordinateur des postes et
télécommunications à l'autre bout de la
ligne c'est mon téléphone qui a permis
de l'appeler monsieur joyeux me dit on y
en a 80 comme ça alors si je regarde la
liste des 80 je vais bien sûr trouver
des noms avec des orthographes voisine
qui m'ont rectifie un peu parce que je
ne savais pas mais je vais pas vous
défiler les 80 alors souvenons nous
monsieur joyeux comment s'appelle-t-il
de son prénom
allez je vous le dis allez-y il
s'appelle noël comme ça c'est gentil
joyeux noël
alors je tape donc noël et cette fois-ci
l'ordinateur va peut-être me le
retrouver plus facilement et joyeux noël
effectivement c'est ce monsieur
j'espère qu'on l'ennuie pas trop parce
que c'est un art véritable qu'on a
appelé dans un bottin véritable ce
joyeux noël dont je pars cacher son
numéro de téléphone
c'est un monsieur très gentil qui nous a
permis de faire ces démonstrations et
alors je vous avais demandé à monsieur
bouvier de la direction des
télécommunications de devenir en tête de
midi pour nous expliquer ce que vous
comptez faire dans l'est dans les années
qui viennent
ce que ça va se développer vraiment
beaucoup de choses beaucoup de choses et
puisque ça a commencé
maintenant en ille et vilaine en
picardie en ile-de-france comme disait
georges leclercq
la suite va venir très rapidement
puisque comme nous l'annoncé le ministre
des ptt hier tous les conseils régionaux
de france ont demandé lave l'arrivée de
la nuit électronique ça va donc se
poursuivre
en ile de france en bretagne en picardie
ensuite la bastide à basse normandie le
nord pas de calais lorraine vous voyez
chefs tribaux tour de france et ensuite
borg en arrivant
alors même si vous faisiez la question
que l'on se pose on se dit bon mahi
veille avoir des ordinateurs
électroniques maintenant fans des
annuaires électroniques que va-t-on
faire des gros annuaire on va les
recycler qu'est ce qu'on a fait d'une
part des jargons les recyclera puisque
il faut bien pouvoir toujours produit
puisque tout le monde n'aura pas en même
temps l'annuaire papier donc en
attendant cette généralisation et bien
le développement de l'annuaire
électronique à ceux qui le souhaiteront
et ensuite le maintien de l'annuaire
papier ça coûte cher de se brancher sur
ce système bien non puisque ce terminal
est mis en place mais bannière
gratuitement pour les abonnés au
téléphone ça remplace admire papier et
ensuite et bien les coûts de
communication téléphonique pour les gens
qui appellent à l'extérieur des murs au
téléphone à l'extérieur du département
puis ce dernier a sert aussi à autre
chose il faut quand même le dire puisque
à des enfants ici avec le minitel on
peut jouer on peut appeler des
informations pratiques des riffs de
vente par correspondance
on peut faire de la formation et puis si
je suis des entreprises et bien je peux
l'utiliser pour une formation inter pour
la gestion interne de l'entreprise voit
ce qui est important dans cette arrivée
la télématique en france plonge
directement dans la galaxie marconi
peut-être pas grave
tout d'abord la plus petite caméra du
monde le plus petit caméscope
c'est à dire caméra plus magnétoscope un
confort
la taille d'un gros livre de poche ne
pèse que 1 kg bourré d'électronique
nouveaux standards vidéo 8 mm la firme
sonic
déjà présenté d'effet que le premier
oui
aujourd'hui canal présente lui aussi son
vidéo vide lacanau vision convient pour
un équipement de cette hambourg
quand même entre 15 et famille je passe
en lecture tous ces matériels devraient
faire qu'une bouchée des lieux super
vite amateurs
bien que les constructeurs prétendent
que le nouveau 8 mm ne concurrencera pas
les autres standards classiques dhs
betamax effet 2010
à vous et moi pas
et bien plus ou moins
terme à la fin de la vidéo de première
génération
le domaine de la photo yves également
l'électronique tous azimuts électronique
qui permet le toujours plus petits
automatique
des appareils sont devenus de véritables
petit robot avec des avantages certains
alors avec ces nouveaux appareils fini
les réglages
fini les mises au point on peut dire
qu'il s'agit d'appareils réellement
sophistiqué qui font de la photo quelque
chose de facile
et malgré tout bon s'agit quand même
d'un matériel qui est à la limite du
professionnel et de l'amateur l'ours ait
pu à loisir bon marché puisque ça coûte
quand même assez cher et je crois que
quand ça peut intéresser beaucoup
beaucoup de monde c'est justement
attention leur plus cher n'est souvent
pas le plus adapté
un peu comme pour le micro-ordinateur
dessus révèle normal qu'il ait pu
regarder quoi si un équipement amateurs
professionnel trois masters à un boîtier
dernier modèle à 5300 francs avec zoom
grand-angle 1828 135
un télé rejet il 4 semble plus des
accessoires flash moteur 4800 francs
environ que l'on ne manquera pas de vous
vendre en tout 17 million c'est cher et
surtout avez vous réellement besoin de
cette technologie perfectionnée
il existe sur le marché d'autres
nouveautés le nombreux et merveilleux
petit compact lui aussi bénéficie vite
face à l'épreuve
en voici un parmi d'autres 1200 francs
seulement je vous dis pas que vous ferez
les mêmes photos bien sûr mais le
premier sourire de votre enfant et aux
vacances
réfléchissez bien avant d'acheter et ne
confondez pas à faire des photos a
habité de la photo